des chapeaux sur mesure mais aussi des
colliers en verre ou des objets et
bijoux en origami
cette boutique éphémère vendée création
de quatre artisanes eurélienne comme
valérie elle fabrique des vêtements pour
bébés depuis un an et demi et cette
boutique était l'occasion pour elle de
faire connaître son travail
l'emplacement était bien pour que la
visibilité soit bonne voilà parce que
sinon je travaille plutôt dans mon
atelier donc c'était bien un moment
donné d'avoir aussi contact avec les
clients chez la première fois que je
vend autant de
de vêtements en petite période c'est
pour moi si une très belle opportunité
une opportunité proposée par
l'association de commerçants les
vitrines de chartres qui souhaitait
mettre en avant le travail de créateurs
locaux mais aussi redynamiser la galerie
marchande du centre ville délaissé par
les commerçants à cause de loyers trop
élevés cette boutique éphémère est née
sur le constat que dans cette galerie de
monoprix en plein centre ville de
chartres
plusieurs cellules commerciales
plusieurs magasins sont fermés depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois donc on avait
besoin de faire vivre ses magasins vides
et de mettre quelque chose à l'intérieur
un avis partagé par les clients ravis à
l' approche de noël de trouver cette
boutique éphémère choc c'est une très
bonne idée surtout en période de fête et
c'est un peu triste une galerie
marchande comme ça avec des boutiques
fermées donc ça donne de l'animation et
c'est parfait ça voilà pousser les
choses très joli c'est plusieurs
créatrices est vraiment de très beaux
objets l'association de commerçants
espèrent ouvrir par la suite d'autres
boutiques éphémères ou à laisser pour
aider les jeunes artisans à voler de
leurs propres ailes